celui qu'on appelle habituellement
l'homme en noir ce jour là c'est une
femme natacha 34 ans passionné de
football depuis l'âge de 9 ans une
passion communiqué par son grand père
depuis 2015
l arbitre comme officiel un match chaque
dimanche c'est un échange qu'on a avec
les joueurs qui est privilégiée sur le
sur le terrain ça fait envie de
s'affirmer aussi et puis c'est une autre
facette de pratiquer le football même si
on n'a pas le même maillot on a
forcément la même passion et on essaie
de partager ça avec avec les joueurs
aussi on n'est pas là pour pour les
remettre des cartes ont systématiquement
mais pour que la rencontre se passe bien
pour le match tout à l'heure il ya une
équipe qui joue un noir une équipe qui
joue en vert les gardiens gris et orange
vérification du terrain des licences
échauffement plus d'une heure avant le
match natacha et ses arbitres assistants
prépare la rencontre dans sa relation
avec les équipes
natacha privilégie la discussion je ne
force pas mon caractère j'arbitre
naturellement j'ai un contact assez
assez facile avec avec les joueurs je
suis pour la communication sur le
terrain donc je pense qu'avec la
communication n'arrive à résoudre
beaucoup de conflits donc j'ai pas de
souci de ce côté là honnêtement avec les
joueurs j'habite principalement que dès
que des hommes c'est assez rare que
j'arbitre sur des matchs féminins dans
le département les femmes ne sont que 7
à officier le district compte 300
arbitres des hommes et des femmes
proposées par les clubs yvelinois en
fonction de leur niveau de compétition
si vous n'avez pas le nombre minimum
d'arbitré vous avez des sanctions pour
calculer le nombre d'arbitrés fournis
par les clubs
quand c'est une arbitres féminines elle
compte pour 2 alors là aussi on m'a dit
stop discret c'est de la discrimination
oui mais elle est positive et j'assume
c'est pour inciter les clubs à nous
amener des arbitres féminines aussi le
district organise chaque année deux
formations pour devenir arbitre
elles ont lieu en octobre et en novembre
natacha delhaize de temps en temps le
sifflet pour taper elle-même dans le
ballon